this year at Wimbledon they weren't just
people watching every surf slice fully
in backhand there was also a computer
quietly Gathering reams of data and
spitting out eerily accurate predictions
on the outcome of each match but this
computer's Ambitions lie far beyond the
tennis court
this is jeopardy the IBM
IBM Watson is probably best known for
its Victorious stint on the U.S quiz
show Jeopardy more than a decade ago
when it first showed off some of
artificial intelligence's potential by
winning the one million dollar top prize
in the years since we've not really
heard much about Watson as IBM has
looked with limited success for ways to
make money from the software the likes
of Google's Deep Mind Microsoft's open
Ai and meta AI research have claimed the
bleeding edge AI research mantle at
Wimbledon and the US Open IBM is trained
to show that AI isn't a future
technology it has applications today we
are basically transforming massive
amounts of data into insights one of the
things that we're doing is the IBM power
index what that's doing is measuring the
momentum and form and performance of a
player so it combines a number of
factors not just the tennis results for
those players but also the buzz in the
media around those players artificial
intelligence generated images voices and
self-driving cars Garner a lot of the
buzz but the reality of how the tech is
used today is actually more of a noun
it's mostly about data analysis
for tennis IBM is leaning on two of its
AI capabilities whilst in Discovery and
what's an open scale you have Watson
discovery which allows us to mine
information unstructured data mostly
text coming especially from a media
coverage there's tons of that as you can
imagine the ability to interpret
unstructured data is one of the novel
elements of IBM's offering it scans data
to infer the broad sentiment towards a
player and then builds this into its
prediction but how successful is it it's
been pretty good I think you know I
think initially we was kind of around
the low 70 in in accuracy I think that's
now getting much more into the 80s so
you know the predictions are pretty good
all this analysis seems like a fun
feature for tennis fans IBM has far
greater aspirations than just sport the
global Sports analytics Market was
valued at 889 million dollars in 2022
and is likely to hit six billion dollars
by the end of the decade for IBM a
company worth from 60 billion dollars in
annual sales that's not a very big price
it is instead more about showing off its
capabilities to other would-be customers
and if you can do this for popular
things like sports then the public will
demand similar constructs when they are
dealing with other kinds of decision
making can Sports analysis popularize
Watson for IBM well it's not the only
company with this idea all its Rivals
are doing the same Hewlett-Packard
Enterprise lends the Formula One racing
team Mercedes-Benz its data analysis
Savvy Oracle works with Red Bull Racing
and sap does something very similar with
the German soccer Champions Bayern
Munich companies tend to accelerate
their Sports sponsorship efforts when a
new market is being created so when cell
phones were gaining mass adoption around
the tone of the Millennium Network
providers splashed heavily on Sports
sponsorship the so-called Advanced
analytics Market is already worth 41
billion dollars and could top 190
billion dollars by 2030. all those Tech
names applying into sports are really
fighting for one piece of that lucrative
pot the audience for IBM's efforts at
Wimbledon isn't necessarily you or me
it's the chief technology officer for a
manufacturer in the Midwest who's
looking for a data analysis firm to make
a factory more efficient that booming
industry will ultimately affect you and
me though say you're going for a job
data analysis tools screen your resume
and personal information to assess
whether you're a suitable candidate need
a loan data analysis might already be
deciding whether to approve you or not
so what you see on the tennis court
today could if IBM has its way be having
an outsized impact on your everyday life
before too long
there's a big competition effort but
we're still only in the early rounds
foreign